good morning Hank it's fried egg ice
what are you doing lying around on the
job show some respect for my audience
that's better so Hank I've been sick
lately in fact I have a note from my
doctor saying I'd ought to do my
punishment but I wanted to continue our
conversation about religion but I also
know that some people find that kind of
boring so here's some dancing dancing
dancing dancing dancing dance dance
dance dance right so Hank in your video
on Wednesday you pointed out how
difficult it can be to answer yes or no
questions like do you believe in God
because you have to define terms like
believe and God also in and that made me
think about how difficult it is to
define any religious identity like for
instance Muslims Muslims believe in the
five pillars of Islam right
you have the Shahada the belief that
there is no god but God prayer at least
five times a day then you have always
giving her zakat the pilgrimage to Mecca
and there's a fifth Marah Madonn right
so those are the five pillars of Islam
the foundation of Islamic belief except
the majority of Muslims don't follow the
five pillars of Islam for instance the
majority of Muslims don't pray five
times a day similarly many Jews don't
practice kosher many Buddhists disagree
radically about the nature of Nirvana
and the path to get there and many
Christians think other Christians are
going to hell because they believe that
Jesus visited America or because they
believed in transubstantiation are all
kinds of things
in fact Hank one time when I was in
college I visited a Pentecostal church
in rural Florida and it was really
interesting there was this one moment
where a woman said to the pastor could
you pray for my sister she's on this
horrible path to damnation she's
completely lost and the pastor was like
yeah what's the problem and the woman
was like she's going to the Pentecostal
church across the street and then the
pastor was like oh yeah that is a
problem so even if you open up all the
matroyshka dolls even within a
particular denomination of a particular
sect of a particular religious tradition
there are still big disagreements I mean
one of the fascinating things about
identifying yourself within a religious
tradition is that no matter who you are
there will always be people within that
very religious tradition who say that
you are not Jewish or Muslim or
Christian or whatever okay this is
getting a little serious let's dance
dance dance dance and dance dance dance
dance dance dance this makes it
incredibly challenging to define the
word Christian or Muslim or Jew because
ultimately there are Muslims who I have
more theologically in common with than
many of my fellow Christians and I think
that's one of the reasons religious
traditions often look back to some point
in history where it seems like things
weren't as fuzzy as they are now like in
Islam there's the age of the golden
Caliphate the first four caliphs in
Christianity there's you know Paul and
the initial
when Christianity was first starting to
grow in Judaism you have the rule of
King David but the truth is that there
was never a golden age and certainly
there's no way to recapture the golden
age by trying to go back to it we know
this Hank due to thousands of years of
failure so how do you know for instance
if you're a nerdfighter you as a
nerdfighter are constantly inventing and
evolving the definition of that word so
please don't forget to be awesome
Hank I'll see you on Monday